how's it going everybody it's Warren and
before we start this video I have to
issue a huge spoiler alert
these pictures are 100% real and they
give away a lot about the rise of
Skywalker including the ending so if you
do not want anything about the rise of
Skywalker spoiled for you I suggest you
click away now alright if you're still
with me as you saw in the title we have
some new leaked images from the rise of
Skywalker and they are absolutely
mind-blowing so let's jump right in but
quick reminder I'm giving away an Xbox
one or a ps4 so be sure to subscribe
like and comment below so you can enter
my giveaway now again these photos are
100% legitimate and it's an interesting
way that we found out that these photos
are in fact real a youtuber posted these
photos on a video and Disney actually
copyright claimed his video that
confirms that these images are in fact
real and Jason Ward from making Star
Wars has confirmed they are real as well
so let's take a look at this first one
so this first one is of Rey and kylo Ren
and as you can see they are clearly on
the same side at this point in time in
the movie they've teamed up we know that
they'll fight in the movie of course but
the reason they decide to put their
differences aside is because of course
there is a bigger threat this bigger
threat of course is Emperor Palpatine
now of course Emperor Palpatine s return
isn't that much of a surprise in fact
everybody pretty much believes that we
saw him in the last rise of Skywalker
trailer and this new leaked photo that
we have today confirms that it was in
fact him in the trailer so as we can see
from this photo Rey is approaching
Emperor Palpatine throne alone which is
interesting because it seemed like in
the previous leaked photo kylo Ren and
Ray were going that Palpatine together
now a lot of people have speculated that
kylo Ren may not make it out of this
movie alive especially with Emperor
Palpatine returning but that's a
discussion for another time all we need
to know is that it seems to be ray
versus Palpatine in this photo and as
you can see Palpatine is shooting forced
Lightning into the air when you look at
this photo you can basically see him
laughing as he shoots forced Lightning
into the air this photo seemingly
confirming what we've expected all along
that Emperor Palpatine has been in fact
behind
everything that we've seen in this
latest trilogy now how does he come back
or how is he survived all this time well
there are a ton of theories out there
right now about how this is possible but
the most popular one right now has to do
with Darth Vader's helmet and the reason
for this is because in the last and
final trailer for the rise of Skywalker
we see kylo Ren and Ray both destroying
at the same time an object that looks an
awful lot like Darth Vader's helmet we
also know that kylo Ren has been
somewhat communicating with Darth
Vader's helmet but perhaps it was not
his grandfather that he was speaking to
perhaps it was Palpatine or Darth
Sidious this whole entire time tricking
kylo regardless of how everything
happens one thing is clear thanks to
these leaked photos
kylo and Rey will become allies and Rey
will go up against Emperor Palpatine so
let me know how you think Emperor
Palpatine returns and definitely let me
know what you think about these leaked
photos be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
also don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 also if you're new I cover
Marvel content Star Wars content and DC
content so if you like those and want to
stay up-to-date be sure to subscribe to
my channel as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof